broadway is not dark anymore and there  are no lambs lying down on broadway  that's a genesis reference curtains rose  last night on broadway for the first  time in more than a year  because of the pandemic now to get  inside these shows ticket holders do  have to show proof they've been  vaccinated against the coronavirus  vaccine and they have to wear masks  it feels great you know  it feels great to talk theater again to  have a line that's so excited to  broadway to return  and it feels good to just see everyone  again and be part of this community  again  i don't think i've seen that kind of  mask before kind of nifty meanwhile the  power of the moment certainly isn't just  being felt by audience members it's also  of course the performers thane jasperson  stars in hamilton  it's electric it's something totally  different like it feels like we're on  fire  broadway contributes nearly 15 billion  dollars to new york city's economy the  show is certainly